well the karate kid is pretty much a
perfect movie there's far more to this
film than sanding floors painting fences
beating up bad guys the behind the
scenes story is equally fascinating
let's take a look at why the Karate Kid
is the best around the saga of Daniel
Larusso and mr. Miyagi all started when
producer Jerry Weintraub saw a news
story about a local kid who earned a
black belt in karate to protect himself
from a group of bullies Weintraub was
immediately inspired and soon enough
Columbia Pictures hired Robert mark came
in to write a screenplay maybe you've
never heard Caymans name you've
certainly seen his movies
the man has written films like Lethal
Weapon 3 the pith elements the
transporter and taken and when he was
approached with the idea of a martial
arts movie came and was able to draw on
his personal experience while writing
the script after all he'd been studying
karate for 17 years he based the
character of mr. Miyagi on one of his
instructors while the character of John
Kriss was a combination of two people
came and had known in real life a tough
marine turned karate teacher and a
martial arts instructor who ordered his
pupils to injure their opponents here on
the street in competition a man
confronts you he's the enemy
other than maybe Yoda or obi-wan Kenobi
mr. Miyagi is probably the greatest
movie mentor of all time Pat Morita is
perfect in the role and his performance
earned him an Oscar nod for Best
Supporting Actor however back in the day
Morita wasn't such an obvious choice for
the parts of a martial arts master he
used to be a comedian and before the
Karate Kid Morita was best known for
playing the comical character of Arnold
on happy days so in director John G
Alton approached producer Jerry
Weintraub with the idea of casting
Marita's Miyagi Weintraub wouldn't even
consider it he was adamant he says I
didn't want a comedian
I'd want a comic actor for this once a
heavyweight part I want an actor
Weintraub wanted to go with legendary
Japanese actor Toshiro Mifune
but avildsen was convinced Morita was
the right man for the job so he went
ahead and did a script reading with
Morita and then surprised Weintraub with
the audition tape the producer was kind
of impressed although he required marina
to audition five more times before
giving him again
but after passing his fifth and final
test Morita finally nabbed the wall
[Music]
believe it or not Ralph Macchio was 22
when he played the part of teenage
Daniel Larusso
but despite the age gap Maggio made for
a perfect protagonist coming off of
Francis Ford Coppola's The Outsiders
Maggio had some steam heading into the
Karate Kid but when it came to landing
the role his snarky attitude is what
really helped him get the gig after
screenwriter Robert mark came in met
Maggio to see if he was right for the
role he came away describing the young
actor is obnoxious and really that's
exactly what came in in John G Appleton
wanted they were looking for somebody
with an attitude a guy who wouldn't take
crap from anyone just like Daniel in
fact they liked Macchio so much that
they kind of rewrote the part for him
originally his character was called
Daniel Weber
but since Maggio was Italian they
changed his last name to Larusso
as for William Zabka the actor who
played bully Johnny Lawrence he probably
got the job thanks to some extreme
method acting when he was first trying
out for the part sabka got so into
character that he actually grabbed
Appleton by the shirt which usually
isn't a smart idea when you're trying to
impress the director but in this case it
seems like Zab cos bad guy persona paid
off because he was cast as the captain
of the Cobra Kai creating one of the
most memorable villains that come out of
the 1980s when Ralph Macchio and company
signed up for the Karate Kid none of
them knew much about martial arts so to
get them ready for a karate tournament
the filmmaker called in Patti Johnson
this guy had studied Tang pseudo while
serving in Korea and when he returned to
America he joined up with Chuck Norris
working at one of Nora's schools soon
Johnson racked up an impressive fight
record and not only would he go on to
work with stars like Brandon Lee and
Jackie Chan he also had a part in Bruce
Lee's Enter the Dragon
in other words Johnson's combat skills
were as legit as they come and when he
was hired as karate kids fight
choreographer he got pretty creative
when it came to instructing the actors
for example he taught Macchio and Morita
together and he made sure to train them
in a very relaxed atmosphere similar to
mr. Miyagi style however Johnson took a
very different approach with a Cobra Kai
he basically put them through boot camp
forcing them to do push-ups and treating
them like soldiers as for the actor who
played crease Johnson explained on a DVD
special feature that he wanted
the kids to view Martin Cove as an
experienced black belt to create this
illusion Johnson trained Koch privately
peeping him away from the rest of the
bad guys that way when Cove met the rest
of the crew they would view him as a
real martial artist Johnson's methods
were pretty clever but his work on the
karate kid wasn't all just behind the
scenes the next time you watch the film
pay attention during the karate
tournament and you'll see the fight
choreographer playing the part of the
mustachioed referee while Johnny
Lawrence is the bad guy we all love to
hate john crease is the real villain of
the Karate Kid
crease is a Vietnam vet who believes in
striking first striking hard and showing
no mercy however many Karate Kid fans
have wondered what the movie would have
been like if the Cobra Kai sensei had
been played by Chuck Norris after all
Norris was offered the part but turned
it down
right yeah I heard that too well
according to CBO calm the Chuck Norris
connection is nothing more than a myth
as it turns out Norris was never offered
the role although if someone had asked
him to play crease Norris says he would
have passed on the part why because he
thought the character cast a bad light
on Karate so while it's fun to imagine
Walker Texas Ranger in the role we can
all agree that Martin Cove was the best
choice this is a karate dojo not a
knitting class you don't come in my dojo
and drop a challenge and leave old man
while pat morita through quite a few
punches in the Karate Kid he wasn't able
to pull off every move required by the
script so when it came time for mr.
Miyagi to do something crazy like jump
off a chain-link fence to give karate
lessons to some bully's stress the
skeletons Morita would step aside for a
real-life martial artist named Fumio de
Muro
de Muro was a regular on the cover of
black belt magazine and he performed in
places like Las Vegas and Paris
eventually demurrer befriended Chuck
Norris and it said the American
recommended him for the parts of mr.
Miyagi according to de Moura he turned
down the opportunity because his English
wasn't good enough although he did
accept the parts as Pat Morita stuntman
doubling for the actor in the first
three films of franchise but while de
Moura is the most famous stunt double in
the film we've got to give a shout-out
to Darrell the doll not only did but
doll play one of the semi-finalists in
the movie's climactic karate tournament
but he's also the guy who doubled for
Morita and the beach scene where Miyagi
froze his graceful crane kick basically
but all is the man who helps
the movies most famous scene so we've
got to give some credit where credit is
due the 1980s was a great decade for
motivational themed songs but few were
quite as inspiring as you're the best by
Joe Esposito this blood pumping anthem
plays during the montage sequence of the
karate kids tournament scene as Daniel
Larusso hits and kicks his way toward
the big showdown with Johnny Lawrence
the song is amazingly epic and
over-the-top but shockingly in some
alternate universe there's a version of
the karate kid that doesn't have it as
it turns out Esposito who would also
contribute to Flashdance and coming to
America originally wrote you're the best
for Rock III however Sylvester Stallone
decided to go with survivors eye of the
tiger instead fortunately for film fans
everywhere director John G Appleton
loved Esposito song and incorporated it
into a spill even though lines like
history repeats itself trying you'll
succeed probably would have fit veterans
to loan spell so basically Iraqis losses
are gain and the song is one of the big
reasons that we still love Esposito
today and being part of such an iconic
film was incredibly rewarding for
Esposito as well as the singer once
explained pop dose I'm thrilled to have
been a part of it it gives me a little
something back for all the years I've
put in don't forget Diamond Vegas
singing in lounges and sometimes it's a
little discouraging but when someone
remembers what I've done from the movie
it makes me feel pretty good it seems
like every time a movie rakes in the big
bucks it doesn't take long before
someone drags the filmmakers into court
unfortunately the Karate Kid is no
exception the trouble all started when a
karate instructor named Bill D Clemente
filed a lawsuit claiming the movie
ripped off his nickname D Clement e's
moniker was indeed the Karate Kid and he
even named his school the Karate Kid
dojo so when the movie came out D
Clemente assumed screenwriter Robert
mark came in had stolen his identity
however a New York courts just didn't
see it that way
sadly for buildi Clemente his case was
crane kicked right out of court when
most people think of the Karate Kid
they remember Daniels bizarre training
regimen or his final confrontation with
Johnny but in between all the fighting
there are a couple of scenes that packed
an emotional punch for example there's a
moment when Daniel finds a drunken mr.
Miyagi wearing a soldier's uniform while
singing a mournful song
so you're singing that jaboney brews hey
Daniel soon learns that his mentor
fought for America during World War two
but despite his patriotism his pregnant
wife was tossed into an internment camp
where she died due to complications
during birth it's a touching moment and
one that was largely inspired by Pat
Morita zone life growing up Morita spent
part of his childhood in an internment
camp for japanese-americans he remained
there for nearly two years of prisoner
who'd committed no crime so when it came
time to film this particular scene
Morita was instrumental in developing
Miyagi's backstory in fact according to
writer Charles C Gooden the song Miyagi
is singing is an actual tune he heard
while in prison amazingly the studio
initially wanted to cut it out but
Morita and John G Appleton stood their
ground and the director believes it was
this scene that earned Morita his Oscar
nominee check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]